next the awards for the best
achievements and short subjects and
cartoons and these will be presented by
one of our most attractive subjects miss
Jeanne Crain
good evening Jeanne they tell me that
there's quite a long list of short
subjects indeed there is Bob the first
classification is for cartoons and those
nominated are the Little Orphan
metro-goldwyn-mayer Fred Quimby producer
okie and the CEO Walt Disney RKO radio
Walt Disney producer Mouse wreckers
Warner Brothers and were Selzer producer
Robin Hood l'm united states productions
of america producer columbia released t
for 200 walt disney RKO radio walt
disney producer the little orphan
metro-goldwyn-mayer Fred Quimby producer
the next classification is the one Ryo
classification Annie was a Wonder
metro-goldwyn-mayer Herbert Moulton
producer Cinderella horse Warner
Brothers Gordon Hollingshead producer so
you want to be on the radio Warner
Brothers Gordon Hollingshead producer
symphony of a city 20th Century Fox
headland H reek producer
you can't win metro-goldwyn-mayer Pete
Smith producer symphony of a city 20th
Century Fox
mr. al brick is accepting the award and
in the to Rio classification Calgary
Stampede Warner Brothers Gordon
Hollingshead producer going to blazes
metro-goldwyn-mayer Herbert Morgan
producer Samba mania paramount Harry
gray producer Seal Island Walt Disney
RKO radio Walt Disney producer snow
capers universal international Thomas
meat producer Seal Island Walt Disney
RKO radio Walt Disney producer mr. van
shark sting will accept the award for
the winner